-Here we go, man.
-Opening the box.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
It's a Slinky with...
some kind of
phallic symbol on it.
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
It's actually a nose
on a Slinky.
-It's a nose on a Slinky.
So I guess they're trying to say
it's a Pinocchio Slinky.
It's a lying Slinky.
I've got a lying Slinky.
[ Laughter ]
Matt and I are about to face off
in the game of "Box of Lies.
[ Scattered "Oohs," cheers ]
Here's how it works.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm gonna lose, really,
is how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects
neither of us
have ever seen before.
Taking turns, Matt and I
are going to select a box
and open it on our side
of the table,
out of view
of the other person.
You remove the object
from the box,
show it to the audience,
then look at your opponent and
tell them what's in your box
You may be lying.
He may be telling the truth.
Your opponent has to guess
either lie or truth.
If you guess correctly,
you get a point,
and you guess wrong,
the other person gets the point.
First to 2 points wins.
Matt, you're our guest.
Why don't you
pick the first box?
[ Cheering ]
-Thank you, Jimmy.
[ Cheering continues ]
[ Audience shouting ]
4? Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
By the way...
Oh, God!
Oh.
-Oh, please.
-It's just so heavy.
I've always wanted to go o
"The Price is Right,"
by the way, and I just lov
that they get the call out
which one I pick.
We make dreams
come true here, man.
Yeah.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Here we go, man.
-Opening the box.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
It's a Slinky with...
some kind of
phallic symbol on it.
[ Laughter ]
It's like --
It's actually a nose
on a Slinky.
-It's a nose on a Slinky.
So I guess they're trying to say
it's a Pinocchio Slinky.
It's a lying Slinky.
I've got a lying Slinky.
[ Laughter ]
-You're saying there's a nos
on a Slinky, and...
-I'm saying I wasn't sure
it was a nose at first,
but, no, it's a nose
on a Slinky.
-If you're making this up,
I have no idea.
Gosh, I'm gonna say you lie!
-It's a bonsai tree
full of gnomes.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
Number!
Which one?!
[ Audience shouting ]
[ Shouting intensifies ]
Oh, this is so light.
I don't even know if there's
anything in it.
Might be feathers.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Interesting.
It's a bowling ball.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
It's an everyday thing.
People have it in their house,
at their office,
you could put it on your desk.
It's a paperweight of sorts.
If you want to do that,
you could use is it as that.
It is a, uh...
It is a hot tub
with Luke Skywalker.
Looks like Luke Skywalker
with Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump.
Could be Justin Bieber.
Justin Bieber, Donald Trump, and
Hillary Clinton in a hot tub
[ Laughter ]
-So it's a --
it's a miniature hot tub..
-Oh, yeah, it's a porcelain --
It's a decent purchase.
It's something you get
in, like, "TV Guide."
You could order it
in "TV Guide."
It's like
from the Franklin Mint.
-Yeah. And in this hot tub
sit three figurines,
one of Donald Trump,
one of Hillary Clinton,
and one either of Justin Biebe
or Luke Skywalker.
We're not.
[ Laughter ]
-The one in the middle
could easily be,
yeah, Mark Hamill --
the actor, Mark Hamill --
maybe not in character as Luke
Young Mark Hamill or...
It's a shirtless Mark Hamill
[ Laughter ]
Hairless.
Shirtless and hairless.
-Shirtless and hairless.
-Which was my first movie,
by the way.
I don't know
if you've ever seen it.
[ Laughter ]
I think I was
an extra in that one.
-Yeah.
All right,
you're telling the truth.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't know what to do
with that.
Well, that was a good lie,
right?
-That was excellent.
-It was a great lie I made
-I figured your producers
might put Donald Trump,
Hillary Clinton,
and Justin Bieber
in a bathtub together.
-Yes! Exactly!
That's what I thought, too
That's the game!
I won!
Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well-played, sir.
Well-played.
-The master!
I beat the master actor.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Our thanks to
the one and only Matt Damon!
I'm here with Adele, and we're
about to face off in a game...
[ Laughter ]
About to face off in a gam
called "Box of Lies."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects neither of us
have ever seen before.
Adele and I are going to
take turns selecting a box
and opening it on our side
of the table
out of view
of the other person.
Once you remove the object
from the box,
you show it to the audience.
Then you look at your opponent
and tell them
what's in your box.
You might be lying.
You might be telling the truth
Your opponent has to guess
either lie or truth.
If you guess correctly,
you get a point.
If you guess wrong, the othe
person gets the point.
First to 2 points win.
Adele is our honored guest
Why don't you pick
the first box?
-Mm-hmm.
Yes, I will.
-Oh, 1...
[ Cheers and applause ]
2.
[ Audience shouting ]
All right.
-Okay.
-Okay. You just gave me
the first hint.
It looks it looks very light
-I've been waiting
my whole life to do this.
-This is it?
This is the big deal?
-It was either this
or the "Lip Sync Battle."
-Oh, yeah!
Well, there's always next time
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
You look confused.
You look very confused.
-Oh.
-All right.
Okay.
-Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
-Mm-hmm.
-I have...
beside me...
-Mm-hmm.
-...on my table...
-Uh-huh.
...T. Rex...
-Okay.
-...dressed up...
-It's a dinosaur.
Mm-hmm.
-...dressed up...
-Dressed up. Okay.
It's a dressed-up dinosaur
-...as a fairy.
-It's a fairy?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's a T. Rex
dressed up as a fairy.
Now, you did this.
The T. Rex's arms are like this.
-Fairies have wings.
[ Laughter ]
You have a daughter.
You should know this.
-I know this, yeah, yeah, yeah
I have two babies, and, yeah
Never seen a dinosaur
dressed as a fairy.
Of course, we could do
anything on our show.
Anything's possible.
But I'm going to say, Adele,
you lie.
-I lie.
-Yeah!
Oh, close!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, that's tricky.
Ooh, I get where --
I get where
you were going with that.
That was tricky, yeah.
-I tried to trick you.
-It was a T. Rex,
and you tried to trick me,
but I could tell you were lyin
because I just trust everythin
except for that.
All right, guys, which ones?
[ Audience shouting ]
5. I got 5.
All right, don't...
-Pfffttt!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God, it's so --
Ooh, boy, oh, boy, oh, boy
Ooh!
Oh, it's so heavy.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a feather.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, chihuahua!
Of course.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
How does this...?
[ Laughter ]
-This better not
be a joke on me.
-No, no, no.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
All right, all right.
In my box...
-Yeah.
-...I have...
[ Laughter ]
It's a G.I. Joe doll
but made into a Santa Clau
and thrown at him
is maybe a candy-cane
Chinese star that is
going to maybe hurt Santa,
but we shall see.
It's not a famous toy,
but this is something
maybe they'll sell
this holiday season.
I don't know.
-So, it's a G.I. Joe.
-G.I. Joe doll, yeah,
dressed as...
-Santa.
With a what?
-It's a...
I think it's a Chinese
throwing star
being thrown at him,
but it's made out of --
-What's a Chinese throwing star?
-It's made out of candy cane
-Okay.
-It's a star.
It's a -- You know?
Never seen a Bruce Lee movie
-No, I don't know if these exist
where I come from.
[ Laughter ]
And what?
It could be scary?
-I don't see it being a
big-selling toy this Christmas
But you never know.
Kids like violence these days.
Who knows?
Maybe I'm lying.
-I'm gonna say
that you're lying.
You lie.
I do lie.
I'm sorry. I was thrown...
This is a nose.
No, no, no, no, no!
[ Laughter ]
No, it's a nose.
This is --
I'm so sorry.
This is like -- I'm sorry.
I didn't want to be
grabby on the things, but...
[ Laughter ]
It's --
I can't even do this.
[ Laughter ]
But they're all noses --
Noses strapped to a...
-Okay.
I don't want that.
I'm sorry. I apologize.
All right.
So, we're tied.
-We're even.
-We're even, yeah.
Whoever wins this one is
the winner and the champion,
and, oh, my gosh,
and the bragging rights
and all that stuff.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-What number?
[ Audience shouting ]
-It doesn't matter!
I'm gonna win anyway.
-Whoo!
-Ooh, very light.
-This is very light.
-Yeah, very light.
You're throwing it around
like nothing -- Ooh!
But then you put it down,
and it's a little loud,
so maybe it's heavy.
It's a plate.
It's ceramic. Yeah!
Ooh-hoo-hoo!
All these hints.
I'm getting all these hints.
You're giving me
all these hints.
♪♪ Da da-da da-da,
deedle dee, dee dee ♪♪
da da, doo-ooh ♪♪
-I have in my box
a giraffe...
-Giraffe.
-...wearing three doughnuts.
[ Laughter ]
Around its neck.
-All right.
A giraffe.
-Mm-hmm.
-"Free" doughnuts.
'at's right.
-A giraffe.
He's got --
-One is dusty, one's got..
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
A giraffe
with doughnuts on his neck
-Giraffe that got
doughnuts on his head.
One, two, "free" of 'em.
-Mm-hmm.
-You're telling the truth.
[ Laughter ]
-Bitch.
[ Dinging ]
♪♪♪♪
What is this, Tony?
Unbelievable.